et voilà qu des réseaux sociaux alors
c'est vrai beaucoup de choses un peu
tout et n'importe quoi sur les réseaux
sociaux mais non s'intéresser surtout à
ce qui fait le buzz en bourgogne franche
comté actuellement et vous avez décidé
tiphaine de nous ramener sur les bancs
de l'école pour un petit flash /
finalement le dernier objet à la mode
kate un retour c'est un stylo que les
enfants ça rech c'est paraît-il le bon
vieux bic 4 couleurs moi je suis
complètement ringard parce que moi j'ai
un feutre ouais je suis complètement
management mais oui c'est pas du tout à
la mode pascal alors ça peut surprendre
puisque le bic 4 couleurs est né en 1970
et à l'époque il s'agissait de remplacer
sa part ça et c'était complètement
novateur mais figurez-vous que donc
cinquante ans après et bien les enfants
s'arrachent le bic 4 couleurs ça peut
surprendre au départ il exister
uniquement en deux couleurs bleues et
orange en fonction de la taille de la
mine mais désormais est bien la folie
des quatre couleurs s'explique par ses
mille et une déclinaison alors je ne
sais pas si vous voyez mais désormais il
y à des collections il y à mille
couleurs il y avait bien la collection
noël par exemple et il ya même des
reliefs par exemple les bic 4 couleurs
en velours les bic 4 couleurs et paix
comme celui-ci dorée des pics en
fonction des saisons par exemple le
nouvel an chinois
donc évidemment les enfants veulent les
collectionner et en avoir un nombre
inconsidérés dans leur trousse et qui
dit collection est bien dit édition
limitée oubliez votre mont blanc pascal
s'est complètement démodée désormais il
faut le bic 4 couleurs version luxe
pensées par le joaillier tournaire avec
l'artiste orlan ce qui vous le voyez là
en or or rose de préférence sertie de
diamants c'est pas cher en 24 milles 550
euros et c'est la vraie glace ah oui on
n'a pas tout à fait la même nation
d'argent 1 quand même 24 milles 550
euros signant linski 10 dont il va
falloir nous faire des stylos à vous
monsieur ben brik là il va falloir me
lancer dans le mal qu alors dites-moi au
musée les retours peugeot ya forcément
laissez-nous vous avez le cas de couleur
vous alors les codes couleurs du style
traditionnel peut-être alors qu'on
réfléchisse voire du bic peugeot 2,3 je
crois monsieur là comme la wii réfléchir
aussi après après c'est une belle
histoire big c'est aussi et ça fait écho
un peu a aussi ses histoires familiales
et de voir aujourd'hui cinquante ans
après avec un même produit de dire moi
ça me rappelle aussi la façon dont les
marques savent se pérenniser et j'ai
beaucoup de respect pour pour ses
aventures qui est qui qui persistent et
qui performent même si j'entends dire
qu'il ya un peu de dérives dans les
cours d'école et qu'il ce trafic un peu
du bic 4 couleurs va cuire plus le cas
de couleur il a complètement changé
tiphaine c'est fini le bleu rouge vert
et noir c'est ça ben oui on a toujours
le bleu rouge vert mais il ya aussi bien
des couleurs pastel ont tout aussi avoir
une version avec laminographie temps
pour dessiner ou bien une version avec
le flux au surligneur un histoire de
compléter sa collection alors imaginer
qu'il se vend en ce moment à peu près 10
millions de bic 4 couleurs par an et je
voulais dire les enfants et collectionne
alors j'ai trouvé une petite fille
maëlys qu'à 14 ans à peu près une ado à
jouannic y en a quand même une vingtaine
dans sa trousse et vous l'avez dit et
bien ça se collectionnent mais ça se
vole aussi malheureusement alors il ya
des établissements dijonnais qui ont
interdit les quatre couleurs en classe
c'est quand même un comble faciale gras
cru bon alors collectionner les stylos
ça franchement toujours existé c'est un
peu comme les porte clés par mois les
calendriers et j'en oublie mais pourquoi
est ce que c'est vraiment un phénomène
de société actuellement tiffen alors
déjà je dirai pas ce que ça touche tout
le monde je vous ai parlé des enfants
mais les adultes aussi se sont mis à
collectionner les bic 4 couleurs alors
peut-être un peu parce que comme les
madeleines de proust on aime à voir cet
objet qui nous suit depuis l'enfance
mais aussi parce que c'est très pratique
alors je sais pas si vous avez remarqué
mais il ya un petit trou donc on peut
passer un cordon et se trimballer
partout dans les couloirs de l'hôpital
par exemple les professions
administratif aussi aime beaucoup le
style aux quatre couleurs j'ai trouvé
une secrétaire de direction qui en a par
exemple 45 c'est peu en vous me direz il
y à aussi est bien une visibilité sur
les réseaux sociaux qui est très
importante qui est un signe quand même
de ce phénomène de société vous allez
trouver les tuto pour tester les
nouveaux modèles comment dessiner avec
un bic 4 couleurs des oeuvres
magnifiques faire une sarbacane
évidemment et puis il ya même des
sketches qui montre que les ados et bien
ont décidé de faire du bic 4 couleurs un
objet incontournable
voilà c'est magique c'est moi j'aime
beaucoup un des bic 4 couleurs je crois
même que vous nous avez trouvé un stylo
d'un joaillier assez particulier avec
des images en prime parce que voilà on
est comme ça on est allé chercher et on
a envie de voir tiphaine
malaisie regarder un jeu je voulais dire
c'est le stylo de tournai requis qui
suscite et bien évidemment toutes les
convoitises allez on regarde le fameux
stylo du joaillier tourneur mais qui
fait fantasmer les petits voleurs
visiblement
moins il garde tout neuf et on s'est
préparé pour ce moment d'accord on en a
volé des stylos des classiques des rares
des pics des légendes et rend les a tous
volée toute notre vie on a volé des
stylos tous les cas troubleront les uns
on les accuse eu d'accord
la personne qui a ce stylo est le
premier rang au milieu fallait s'y
attendre et nous on au dernier rang
fallait s'y attendre
on va mettre un peu en place j'ai mis un
plan place on va y aller en 4 à 2 vous
deux vous allez la déconcentrer vous
deux vous allez la déconcentrer voulu
parler d'école à ce qu'elle aime sans
alcool moi j'y vais
le stylo dans ma poche il ya même des
sketches assez incroyable pour terminer
la saison voulez vous vraiment vous
montrer ça parce que franchement ça
c'est fou quoi bah oui ça m'a fait rire
alors évidemment si vous êtes plutôt
dans un esprit décroissance sachez que
vous pouvez avoir un seul style aux
quatre couleurs échangés mine alors les
mines c'est pratique ça se change tous
les 8 km environ donc vous voyez il ya
un petit peu de marche quand même pascal
elbé parfait le stylo quatre couleurs de
beats la nouvelle folie des écoliers à
attention aux trafics de faux stylo
parce que bic est victime de son succès